y las celdas electroquímicas metal aire
son relativamente un nuevo tipo de
fuente de energía portátil que consisten
en un ánodo metálico una pasta
electrolítica alcalina que contiene agua
y como cátodo una membrana porosa que
permite la entrada de oxígeno del aire
un esquema de la celda se muestra arriba
aquí podemos ver las diferentes partes
este es el ánodo metálico que como es un
ánodo es la terminal negativa de nuestra
fuente de energía será la fuente de
electrones también tenemos una pasta
electrolítica alcalina que contiene agua
voy a subrayar eso porque es muy
interesante pasta electrolítica alcalina
que contiene agua es esta de enmedio y
cuando decimos que es alcalina eso
significa que será básica es decir que
tendrá un ph mayor a 7 pasta
electrolítica un electrolito es algo que
sí lo disolvemos en una sustancia polar
como el agua al estar en solución es muy
conduciendo electricidad entonces esto
nos dice que la pasta electrolíticas era
algo que es bueno conduciendo
electricidad y nos dicen que es alcalina
así que será básica tendrá un ph mayor a
7 y de este lado como acá todos tenemos
una membrana porosa que permite que
entre el oxígeno del aire entonces este
es el cátodo y es la terminal positiva
aquí es a donde los electrones se
sentirán atraídos y es una membrana
porosa que permite que entre el oxígeno
del aire entonces podemos ver que el
oxígeno está disponible en esta membrana
de alguna forma permite que se filtre
porque es porosa los potenciales de
reducción para el cátodo y tres posibles
a nodos metálicos están dados en la
tabla de abajo
recuerden para los potenciales de
reducción
la reducción significa ganar electrones
entonces este es el potencial al ganar
electrones esa es una forma de verlo
o es una reacción que de alguna manera
involucra electrones y de este lado
tenemos oxígeno molecular reaccionando
con agua por cada molécula de oxígeno
molecular tenemos dos moléculas de agua
cuatro electrones y reaccionan para
formar cuatro aniones hidróxido entonces
nuevamente esta es una reacción de
reducción porque esos electrones son
incorporados en la molécula y así nos
queda el hidróxido aquí pero si
analizamos la celda metal aire eso donde
ocurre bueno necesitamos oxígeno agua y
electrones entonces si analizamos el
cátodo aquí los electrones están
entrando el oxígeno entra y podemos
suponer que el agua está disponible en
esta área
la pasta electrolítica tiene agua y el
cátodo es poroso todos están disponibles
y podemos suponer que esa reacción puede
ocurrir justo aquí en el cátodo voy a
escribir o dos gaseoso
más por cada molécula de otros tendremos
dos moléculas de h2o en estado líquido
después tenemos los electrones
provenientes del alambre y eso produce 4
aniones hidróxido cuatro uniones
hidróxido y están en solución son parte
de la pasta electrolítica que está
disuelta en el agua porque recuerden que
es una solución acuosa entonces esto es
lo que va a ocurrir los anones hidróxido
bueno de hecho podemos decir cuatro años
es hidróxido serán producidos cada vez
que ocurra esta reacción y nos dicen que
el potencial de reducción es un
potencial positivo tiene un voltaje
positivo
y miren aquí dice que es el potencial de
reducción a un ph de 11 eso coincide con
nuestras condiciones alcalinas porque
esta pasta puede filtrarse un poco por
aquí y obviamente tenemos todo este
hidróxido produciéndose así que
tendremos un ph mayor y más básico bueno
regresando al hecho de que es un voltaje
positivo más 0.34 volts esto significa
que el potencial va en esta dirección el
potencial eléctrico favorece que la
reacción ocurra de izquierda a derecha
ahora también nos dicen que nos dan los
potenciales de reducción para el cátodo
que es de lo que ya hablamos este es el
potencial de reducción para el cátodo y
tres posibles a nodos metálicos están
dados en la tabla de abajo aquí tenemos
tres posibles a nodos metálicos
podríamos tener zinc sodio o calcio pero
empecemos con el zinc que es el primero
vamos a suponer que el metal que tenemos
aquí
qué pasará bueno el zinc reaccionará con
los hidróxidos que se producen en el
cátodo y después usaremos eso para
producir óxido de zinc agua y electrones
así que ocurrirá la reacción inversa de
este lo escribiré tenemos zinc en estado
sólido todo el ánodo está hecho de zinc
metálico y luego por cada molécula de
eso necesitamos dos años es hidróxido
que están disueltos en agua eso es lo
que hace alcalina a la pasta
electrolítica y luego van a reaccionar
para formar óxido de zinc óxido de zinc
en estado sólido
más agua en estado líquido más dos
electrones entonces esta reacción es la
que sucede aquí observen que los años es
hidróxido se forman en el cátodo y
después se mueven hacia la izquierda
para reaccionar con el zinc y así formar
óxido de zinc entonces tenemos más y más
óxido de zinc formándose y el agua que
regresa de nuevo a la pasta
electrolítica eventualmente volverá a
reaccionar en el cátodo y también
tenemos estos dos electrones que se
convertirán en fuentes de electrones
aquí y que después migrarán y pasarán al
lado positivo el cátodo para reaccionar
de nuevo así que empezamos a ver esto
como una fuente de energía y podemos
usar esta corriente que se forma al
hacer un trabajo útil para eso tenemos
una fuente de energía ahora que ya
logramos un entendimiento decente de lo
que ocurre veamos las preguntas
a formas tempranas de celdas metal aire
usando zinc como ánodo como en el
ejemplo que acabamos de ver el óxido de
zinc se produce conforme la celda opera
de acuerdo a la siguiente reacción por
cada dos moléculas de zinc y una
molécula de oxígeno molecular producimos
dos moléculas de óxido de zinc usando
los datos de la tabla de arriba calcula
el potencial de la celda para la celda
zinc aire
vamos a ver podemos separar esta
reacción en dos pasos porque observen
que las cosas que están reaccionando son
zinc voy a resaltarlo zinc
y también tenemos oxígeno oxígeno
entonces si invertimos la segunda
reacción como antes voy a escribir la
bueno escribiré las dos la primera
reacción nos queda como a dos gaseoso
más dos h2o en estado líquido más cuatro
electrones y eso produce cuatro años es
hidróxido en solución acuosa y después
en esta reacción vamos a ir en la
dirección contraria entonces tenemos
zinc
en estado sólido más dos años es
hidróxido
y eso produce óxido de zinc en estado
sólido más agua líquida más dos
electrones entonces cuando analizamos
esto podemos ver que está reaccionando
tenemos el oxígeno el zinc que son las
dos cosas que interactúan aquí y si
queremos que sean equivalentes en
términos del número de moléculas podemos
decir ok si tenemos una molécula de
oxígeno molecular y necesitamos dos de
zinc hay que multiplicar esta reacción
por 2 entonces 252 moléculas de zinc
reaccionan con 4 hidróxidos para
producir 2 óxidos de zinc 4 perdón dos
moléculas de agua
y 4 electrones entonces digo oh sí esta
reacción ocurre dos veces entonces
tenemos el doble de reactivos y de
productos y observen que ahora tenemos
una molécula de oxígeno molecular dos
moléculas de zinc una molécula de
oxígeno molecular y dos moléculas de
zinc y si todo esto ocurre vamos a
producir dos moléculas de óxido de zinc
y bueno que hay de todo lo demás que
puse en estas reacciones bueno el agua
está aquí pero también aquí tenemos dos
moléculas de agua y dos moléculas de
agua entonces en la reacción total esto
se cancela es neutro es decir no
producimos ni perdemos agua y luego
tenemos cuatro electrones cuatro
electrones por eso no están en la
reacción total y estas cuatro moléculas
de arn iones hidróxido se usarán en la
segunda parte de la reacción se producen
pero se consumen y si analizamos la
reacción total bueno claro
podemos ver que estamos usando el
oxígeno molecular y el zinc para
producir óxido de zinc y nos dicen
usando la tabla de arriba calcula el
potencial de la celda para la celda zinc
aire ok bueno el potencial para la
primera reacción es mas 0.34 volts y
ahora cuál es el potencial para la
segunda reacción bueno como es la
reacción inversa de ésta esta reacción
tiene un potencial negativo y al
invertir la el potencial será positivo
entonces más 1.31 volts ahora algunos de
ustedes tal vez estén pensando bueno no
solamente le invertimos sino que también
la multiplicamos por 2 no necesitaríamos
multiplicar el voltaje por 2 bueno si
solo estuviéramos hablando de la energía
que se libera en la reacción si
absolutamente si tenemos dos veces la
misma reacción tendremos el doble de
energía pero recordemos que el voltaje
lo podemos ver como energía potencial
por unidad de carga y si hacemos más de
esto eso no cambia el voltaje actual eso
es muy importante y si multiplicamos
ambos lados por 2 multiplicaríamos la
energía liberada o tomada por 2 pero
como estamos hablando de voltaje el
voltaje no es una cantidad que dependa
del número de cargas o el número de
moléculas que tengamos sino que es un
potencial por unidad de carga esa sería
una forma de verlo
entonces para esta pequeña reacción
simplemente sumamos estos dos voltajes y
nos queda 1.65 volts ahora vamos con la
segunda parte la pasta electrolítica
contienen iones hidróxido en el diagrama
de la celda de arriba dibuja una flecha
para indicar la dirección en la que
migran los iones hidróxido a través del
electrodo conforme la celda opere bueno
ya habíamos pensado en eso el hidróxido
se produce en el cátodo con esta
reacción y se consume en él
así que el hidróxido se moverá en esta
dirección